think about this question what is that
opposite of unpredictable
give me another word
no it's not no type in unpredictable
synonym level headed
unpredictable what what is so it's it's
a very simple word just take the u
yeah that's i mean and i'm not even
american i wasn't born here the opposite
of predictable is unpredictable is
predictable
and when it comes down to
war the last thing you want to be is
what predictable here's what's crazy
isn't it crazy that the guy that the
world thought was going to start world
war iii
the world was at peace and the guy that
thought that was going to bring world
peace has created the world into mayhem
everybody thought biden was going to
bring a lot of peace it's been a [ __ ]
show when it comes down to safety
and everybody thought trump was going to
bring war
the only place that was a [ __ ] show was
on twitter okay when when when he was
here
to me um okay so let's if you have a
follow-up i can go with other questions
if you don't have a follow-up form did
you have a follow-up question on that
topic or trump
so let me continue so i would go to this
with you
um
so you know historically which political
party typically likes war
it's fine which histori which political
parties are you saying the republicans
the warhawks
asking you what would you say
historically hopefully neither party
like no or no that's not true though
that's not true historically republican
okay so people will typically say
you know when it when it comes down to
the republican party is like feeding war
like even if you watch the movie vice
the way they built dick cheney and you
know what he did to get all those
contracts okay cool
so iraq all of that yeah now if you go
back if you go back to bush can somebody
say well that was true
that was the case right there was a lot
of war okay well if you go to obama
do we have wars during obama how was
under obamacare
a war every day we feared isis right i
mean isis was like that was the media
though just like cody but no no but but
but that the media is on his side that's
talking isis that's his side it's not
99 of the media loved and adored obama
so if the media is talking about it it's
real because obama was president not
because somebody on the opposite side
was president so you can't confuse the
two and you bring to trump
the four years is pretty quiet nothing
really happens palestine and you know
kushner does what he does and then you
have now biden so
this is the question i got for you is
you're putin the guy that you're saying
one of his advisors the general hey why
don't we do a super emp on ukraine and
maybe even nato you were talking about
that earlier 40 minutes ago
and
you know but at the same time again
you know let's go into the mind of putin
today
uh biden just gave ukraine 40 billion
dollars it's public you know
so we're going to support ukraine
and uh uh biden's become a friend of
ukraine a lot of people on the media
support that decision they say that was
a good move to be made
uh
nato is defending anybody against russia
almost everybody against russia
how is putin
sitting there saying
these guys don't fear me because if if
you look at that picture between these
two guys you got trump and putin okay
what do both of them have in common both
of them if there's an area they're
competing in
is which man is more unpredictable to
impose fear okay would you agree with
that both of them are in a way
unpredictable right now you want the guy
that's unpredictable
to be on your side the guy that's
unpredictable that's not on your side
you don't like that but if the guy is
unpredictable and he's on your side
you're good with that both of these guys
are unpredictable
how is an unpredictable putin process 40
billion dollars being given to ukraine
and public humiliation and he's sitting
there saying well you know maybe we'll
take a little bit more maybe they're
going to finally figure out that i'm a
good guy and what do you think he's
thinking right now how much more can he
sit there and keep taking all the
support that ukraine is getting rather
than leaving that alone okay before i
answer that question i'd just like to
clarify what i said about president
trump before because i'm a trump admirer
i don't want that being misconstrued
you know we had started off you know
you know because i don't want it
misunderstood that i was criticizing
president trump when i said well he said
that our military was the strongest in
the world when that was not so okay
uh
it is the case that if you look at our
forces and what was done you know
there's no way that in the four years of
the trump administration we could have
gone we could have modernized our
nuclear forces so so quickly uh uh you
know it wasn't true that we had the
strongest military in the world our
nuclear forces certainly were still
far behind and our military forces were
not prepared yet to fight a can a pure
competitor a conventional level
you know but i support president trump
saying those things because he's the
president what is he supposed to say oh
our nuclear forces are uh are far
inferior to those of russia but i'm
spending money and i hope that in 30
years we can catch up with them that
wouldn't be a prudent thing for a
president to say the president has
always got to say we're the strongest
we're the best we can beat anybody so
you know from a military technical
analytical point of view uh you know uh
those things were weren't literally true
but in terms of what presidents are
supposed to do yes you know i'm i'm glad
president trump was saying that he's not
just communicating the american people
all the bad guys in the world are
listening to him and if they had the
sense that oh this guy
is admitting publicly that america is
weak you know you don't want to do that
biden in effect is doing this now uh
when he decides uh you know that uh that
we're going to cancel the sp over the
protests of all of over the pentagon you
know that he's defunded this slickman
the sea launched cruise missile nuclear
was our only hope to catch up with
russia in terms of our tactical nuclear
weapons and he's also
cancelled the b83 nuclear bomb you know
which is the only weapon that it's the
our last megaton class weapon that had
some kind of a chance of driving a
shockwave that could destroy command
bunkers in russia and he canceled that
in the middle of this profound nuclear
crisis over ukraine what kind of signal
is that sending them it tells them that
he's afraid of nuclear weapons or
indifferent to the nuclear balance to
such an extent that even this kind you
know he's he's defunding and canceling
some of our best weapons so having said
that how does putin processing 40
billion dollars sent to ukraine well uh
you know we know how he's processing it
and he's basically telling his people uh
uh that uh that the war in ukraine uh
you know is not just a war against
ukraine but the that ukraine is a proxy
war being waged by the united states and
nato against russia
uh and uh and he and he's basically
saying you see i was right to invade
ukraine even though things aren't going
well i was right uh because ukraine in
effect is a de facto member of nato and
these guys are planning to use the uh
ukraine to try to destroy russia they're
doing it now uh you know uh there's all
this nonsense that we didn't have to
worry about nato and ukraine is proven
false because they're basically treating
ukraine as a de facto nato member now
they're still afraid enough afraid of us
because of our nuclear capabilities that
they're not willing to directly engage
russian troops uh you know uh there but
we this proves that it was right and
that we have to prevail in ukraine
because this poses an existential threat
uh in effect we're in world war three
right now a world war iii is being waged
against russia via via ukraine as a pro
a proxy war and uh the russian people
are listening to this you know putin is
far more popular among the russian
people now than uh than biden is among
the american people you know he has
tremendous support for prosecuting that
that war and winning it and uh
i think as i as we discussed in the last
program
what is putin going to do
uh
you know we don't the fog of war is so
thick over ukraine you know we don't
really know
you know just how bad is the situation
for russia and for putin
internally we're almost all the
information we're getting is coming from
the ukrainians on the battlefield and
from a biden administration that wants
to make the russians look as bad as
possible you know because biden doesn't
want the narrative to be about
biden throwing away 60 years of u.s
national security credibility on the
international stage when he drew that
line in the sand and told putin do not
invade ukraine and then russian tanks
ruled right over it you know he doesn't
want the conversation biden
administration doesn't want the
conversation to be about that they
wanted to be about how badly the
russians are doing allegedly doing maybe
in reality doing so badly
uh you know uh in in
in ukraine and and therefore uh uh you
know the politics are not so bad for
biden
from that from that perspective so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]